[Music]
the pandemic caused many people to
reevaluate their careers and millions of
others were forced out in what's being
called the great resignation it isn't
stopping new numbers show 4.3 million
people quit or change their jobs in
january that is exactly what happened to
former media executive ron king he had
to say goodbye to his high-powered role
but as our lead national correspondent
david begno discovered in losing his job
he found himself in a very unexpected
place surrounded by
donkeys
david good morning how about that y'all
better get ready for this ride if you've
ever been fired or laid off from a job
for whatever reason and you started
searching for what was next what really
mattered to you
then this story is for you
[Music]
among the coastal hills of northern
california right in the middle of wine
country
my favorite part of my day is my donkey
hood
ron king has created a donkey sanctuary
it's the weight of the head that lets
you know he is like happy
this is so sweet
this 75-acre ranch is a non-profit
dedicated to their rescue and
rehabilitation they're intelligent and
they have very high emotional
intelligence i give them love and they
give me love back
i'm a donkey guy now it's a far cry from
his pre-pandemic life a tired and gucci
shuttling between new york and los
angeles as a senior vp for time inc he
managed sales and marketing for some
well-known brands was there a moment in
your life where you thought damn i've
made it yeah i think it was when you
know i was flying first class to milan
to sit front row at versace that was a
big deal but in 2018 the sale of time
led to the elimination of king's
position so he freelanced but then covet
hit the work dried up and the despair
set in
then came a call from an old friend phil
selway a prominent pop art dealer he
hired ron to move to his ranch and sell
it because it wasn't being used i
thought it would be a win-win he could
help me tremendously and it would help
him give him another project king took
the job and while hiking around the
property he felt something new this
sense of calm my head is always like a
snow globe that's being shook it never
stops that sense of sort of chaos in my
head was just normal for me when the
snow globe stops after 20 years you feel
that but you were still enough to
recognize that still enough to recognize
it and respectful enough to act on it i
had no thoughts in my head
except this beautiful surrounding and i
realized it was the first time i've felt
serenity in 20 years
well serenity met serendipity
king discovered a story about the plight
of donkeys known historically as strong
pack animals capable of hauling goods
but they've outlived their usefulness so
donkeys which can live around 30 years
are sold at auction slaughtered and then
skinned for their hides to be used for
traditional chinese medicine they don't
have any advocates they don't win races
they don't feed a food chain and i
thought
i need to help donkeys so i said bill
i have an idea that i want to run by you
i want you to take it off the market not
sell it and let me turn this into a
donkey sanctuary that sounds bananas and
he
he will tell you he also said it sounded
bananas the first thing i thought when
ron was giving this presentation was
that he was crazy and i would be crazy
to go along with this it's absolutely
blown me away and i could not be happier
donations support their cause
every donkey here 97 of them while we
were there would have been killed
patches was dying of starvation so
nobody had fed him for who knows how
long
the only way to help a donkey that's
been abused emotionally recover
is to love it back to health and i had
this moment where i realized that
there's a difference between things that
i enjoy
and things that bring me joy
and i was 52 years old when i realized
those were two different things it's a
whole different way of living you will
never be this sick again and in helping
donkeys to heal he may be healing his
own invisible scars
king's struggles began at an early age
when this son of a southern baptist
preacher first realized he was gay they
were young and they were religious and
they had a little [ __ ] boy so that
didn't go well
all i really wanted all along was to
matter
come on
by his 20s he was homeless addicted to
drugs and alcohol he got sober only
after surviving an overdose
understanding the power of resilience
you wanted to take the donkeys hiking
yes sir keep these guys fit
king rebuilds the donkey's strength and
trust so that they're ready for adoption
so far he's found forever homes for 30
of them
for a long time
proving that i could be someone or be
something
motivated me that part has gone but i
want to matter
to the world to the donkeys to
people
huh we have so many snuggle seshes amber
paz made two of his donkeys part of her
family this is my dream come true i
don't think i've ever met anyone who
dreamed of a donkey they're just
absolutely precious
for paz it was love at first sight she
laid down right next to us i went you're
mine i went into this not knowing how to
do all this but
if i can do it anyone can do it run run
there is no denying the connection that
donkeys form with people
you know changing lives may be a heavy
burden for a lot of people
but it is a load that these animals seem
to haul with grace
i was pretty accomplished by all those
standards
and i found myself with the rug pulled
out from under me
and
for that level of despair to be so close
so recent
is really an important lesson in
resilience and and turnaround
good morning
there is light at the end of the tunnel
and it's not always a freight train
sometimes it's
donkeys
you know donkeys are a lot like dogs
when it comes to affection i learned
this place is called oscar's place and
the deal is he'll adopt a donkey to you
but only two at a time because he
doesn't want one to be lonely
my children ask for a donkey three two
one just just make some space i love the
moment where he says i realize there are
things that you enjoy and there are
things that bring you joy so i think the
question is this morning and i would say
to everybody watching what is it that
brings you joy ask yourself that what is
it that brings you joy and then get
about the business i mean i i i am i
feel partial to the story because i
asked myself that very same question
when i traded one life for another right
back when i made it right change but he
said he always wanted to matter then he
goes on to say the donkeys don't have
any advocates they don't win races they
don't feed a food chain and so i need to
help the donkeys so ron you matter
that's right and what i love about this
story is that donkeys are known to carry
heavy loads with ease and it seems like
they have essentially lifted the burden
off of his shoulders and they made him
mad
if i had drums
that's really it i mean that that's
everything and and this man who was in
the rat race of keeping up and looking
like the joneses is now sitting in you
know what in the middle of a field in
northern california and he's never
been happier mm-hmm well done the
donkeys are actually intelligent very
intelligent animals super smart they
also like their ears robed
don't we all
don't we all rub a donkey ear don't we
all bring a donkey with you next time
okay
all right david bagno thank you so much